hey guys mister guys they're firing
missiles at us
we gotta head to the graveyard hey guys
can you cover me while I place the
thermal detonators very great thanks
dude I'm so high right now
nice okay guys the detonators are in
place let's go find these rebels and
kill their booties dude I met this girl
at Starbucks today she had a septum
piercing and some big old nipples
[ __ ] man can you help me find a
girlfriend by this weekend
I'm telling you max you totally want her
to bone me yeah I hear ya I have a big
crush on Carmen the girl that works at
Gamestop you guys have seen her right I
heard you guys have her number can you
hand it over to his please [ __ ] I'm
gonna use the night yeah you do it you
guys want to come over on Saturday I got
some nudie mags
don't worry Nana's gonna the carnival
it's Ladies Day don't I wanna bang her
Nana so bad she's like a female Bernie
Sanders dude that's so rude that's my
grandma she gave birth to my mom and my
mom keep earth to me my dad's getting
remarried on Saturday
mom cheated on him oh [ __ ] yeah but my
dad he's sucks so it's okay I feel you
man I feel you but maybe to get your
mind off all that [ __ ] come on my
birthday party it's coming up I'm
thinking either Disneyland and then a
strip club or or the other way around
doesn't matter whatever you guys decide
is cool boom hell yeah so the guys get
my my birthday list I emailed it to you
check your spam folder it's called genes
birthday list let me know if you got it
yeah oh yeah oh yeah Zack I figured
since your brother - Lucas works at Best
Buy you could get me that expansion pack
cuz and here you can get like different
colored helmets
I'd love a red wine blower that's uh
hold on okay and max I'd really like
that new virtual controller I heard you
have an Amazon coupon for $10 you could
just apply that to the purchase that'd
be great thanks you guys I just got shot
that's not cool I thought you guys with
my friends you didn't cover my ass
I'm gonna stop saying prayers for you
guys at night I've been praying everyday
that you guys are second maximum or best
friends Jesus take care of them die from
the bottom now we're here we won the
game grab my holiday right yeah oh did
you hear that some other boys are you
guys talking about me yeah sounds like
some nerd ghost
why are you for real are you talk about
Miriam